this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast the most successful
minimalism podcast in the world
oh my god that's news to me breaking
news ryan
oh my god it's funny man uh
obviously joking about that i mean yeah
you could look at stats or numbers or
whatever and determine success but
that's really what i want to want to
talk to you about today
about success about failure about
fulfillment about
satisfaction and about how incessantly
chasing these things
is not fulfilling right
it's uh it doesn't create fullness it
creates
fullness oh it's a double entendre
successful is the title of this episode
made me think about uh like buddha was
buddha the most successful buddhist
yeah well right and the question i
actually wrote down the very first thing
when i think about success when i was
walking into
the studio i was thinking about this
who's the most successful child you know
um
and like i wouldn't even know what that
would mean right like it could mean like
maybe they're a child star and they have
what more
followers on instagram or something but
is that really a measure of success
certainly not a measure of success for
being a child yeah if we're talking
about being a child there's no such
thing as
the most successful child right and
when we think about success i think we
often look towards
magazines or now it's instagram right
where
it's the really nice suit that you used
to wear and you would see it in the gq
in your 20s or the lexus that i
drove or the big house and the excerpts
that i had
these are all sort of signifiers in and
this is this is the key here in our
culture
for success in other cultures people
might look at that and say
well that's so silly why would you have
such a big house
wouldn't it be lonely there or why do
you need to wear that
piece of cloth around your neck that is
a very strange thing or
why are all of those logos on that
handbag
i don't even know why you need the
handbag but why do you need the logos
there oh it's a signifier
it's simply saying let me signal to you
my socioeconomic status or my
aspirations
my success yeah and so when we think
about success don't we often
look at maybe your career the job title
we we often look at the amount of money
either in your bank or the amount of
money you make
right we look at the trinkets that you
amass the average american household has
300 000 items
in it and that's not good or bad but
my argument for all of this is that or
my thoughts on this
is that success
is often failure hmm often i could see
that
it's interesting i'm thinking about a
friend a mutual friend we have
who is from belfast and
they have a very wealthy friend who
lives in belfast that bought a maserati
and they were like driving around
belfast in their maserati
oh wow and they ended up getting rid of
it because they did feel alienated
because no one else
it was like the only maserati on the
road in belfast
oh and so that that highlights something
fascinating doesn't it ryan because
we all want to be significant in a way
and so we often signal success
look at me i'm different from you we
also
want to fit in we want to have
connection and love with other people
and so if i'm so different from you
then i miss out on the sort of
interconnectedness
of people and and so my indictment is
not on
success my indictment is on society's
view
of a measured version of success and
maybe what we can do today is sort of
work to redefine success because right
now
when we look at success we look at at
the form
of success the trinkets that i mentioned
the cars the
the suits the beautiful dresses and the
purses and there's nothing inherently
wrong with these things
it's not immoral to own a maserati
it is immoral to run someone over with
your maserati on purpose right
right and so when we're talking about
success or failure
it's not a good or a bad thing
necessarily but
unfortunately the problem happens when
we confuse the form
for the essence and and so
we look at that advertisement
in the magazine in fact you and i
reviewed last week or a couple weeks ago
with bex we were doing the how to love
episode on the minimalist podcast we
on the the private podcast we we broke
out this louis vuitton ad
and it was a great metaphor of like all
this baggage that was keeping
the person in the ad from actually
exploring the beauty of the world and so
the thing that actually made them look
successful was getting in the way
excuse me the thing that was that made
them look successful was getting in the
way of
of life of living and isn't that true
all the things that we
pursue many of them
as i create my life i'm not actually
living in fact that creation
the amassing gets in the way of the
living the
experience and so i thought i'd start
with a question here i've gotten various
versions of this question ryan
over the last few months as we've been
exploring these different topics
especially over
on the private podcast so i wrote this
question down this is an amalgamation of
maybe a dozen or two dozen questions
people have asked me but it's base it
basically goes like this
is joshua fields milburn a buddhist now
or is he a christian a nihilist an
existentialist
an epicurean a stoic a quietist
or something else first i'd like to say
that
i tend to avoid isms the only ism i like
is minimalism
and the reason i avoid ism isn't just a
suffix that means i
the ideology of right and so
i'm okay with consumption when we turn
it into an ism consumerism
i have a lot of problems with that
minimalism seems to be an ism that is
by its very nature devoid of ideology
now someone can create their own
ideology and call it minimalism
but when you and i talk about what we
talk about ryan we're not talking about
dogma we're not prescribing a a
13-step program to live a more minimal
life we're sharing some recipes
and and by sharing those recipes
occasionally
some people or in some cases a lot of
people get value from
those recipes applying them to their own
life but we're certainly not saying
this is what you must do this is what
you should
do i got this text message from
laura the other day and i responded back
to her i wanted to read it to you ryan
by the way you can text us 937-202-4654
she said hey josh fellow intj here
so she's an introvert uh intj i'm
probably an insj i sort of
fluctuate between the two um anyway she
says i am new to your podcast and have
been
gobbling it up it's put verbiage to a
lot of things i have been feeling for
years so thank you
it feels like a cheat code using all
your years of experience condensed
and articulated so well i told you we
were successful ryan
you have a very very well thought out
ideas thank you thank you thank you
um all right it is striking to me that
you don't
seem to have figured out what you
personally believe about creation god
hmm yeah right that's where it goes here
say it again so
you have a very well you have very well
thought out ideas in so many areas
except spirituality it is striking to me
that you don't seem to have figured out
what you
personally believe about creation and
god or maybe you're just not willing to
share it
and uh it goes on several other
paragraphs here
but let me just say this um you say
accept spirituality and i find
find this fascinating yes i think we're
all sort of seeking i'll read my
response
to her ryan i just sent her a text
message just said it's wonderful you're
getting value from the podcast yes
i'm certainly inspired by christians
atheists buddhists stoics
quietest existentialists and even
nihilists to some extent
i'm not going to pick a team though
since i find wisdom
in each of those traditions besides it's
not about what i
quote believe it's about the truth
and our beliefs often cloud the truth
if i outline with any one thinker above
all others it's probably anthony demelo
who was a jesuit priest whose book
awareness
changed the way i see the world you and
i have talked about the book awareness
before on this podcast briefly i read an
excerpt on the
politics 2020 or what was it the
election day 2020 episode
also kapil gupta md who is an agnostic
or maybe even an atheist
his book direct truth opened my eyes
to see the truth and
i responded to laura this way because i
often think
teams are the problem when we talk about
picking a team or picking an ism or
picking a dogma i don't have a problem
with any of these like i said i find
great wisdom in all of these these sort
of isms
and i try to find ingredients from those
that
help deprogram me in a way help wake me
up
in a way without having to drag
every piece forward
right yeah i mean with spirituality of
it's like i don't know
that's why i don't talk about it and i'd
actually have become comfortable with
not knowing and to plant my flag
or to plant our flag in any type of
spiritual belief
it's actually divisive you're alienating
certain people when you plant your flag
so
i used to think the term agnostic was
kind of a cop-out
you believe or you don't believe man but
it's like
i don't know that gray area of being
agnostic just kind of
and what i mean by that is just being
open to everything like that's i think
that's more
valuable because you can look at all the
wisdom from the different philosophies
and take a little bit
a little ingredient uh here and there um
but it's interesting because this says
more about this person who's texting us
right
sure yeah and by the way most of our
texts are they're great i just get and
by the way this is not a
bad text or anything no it's a good
topic usually people are saying like
here's a picture of something i i
decluttered recently and we'll send them
back an emoji or a thank you or whatever
a lot of people calling me a chair
lately
that was hilarious
i'm not a chair everyone listen to this
i am not a chair well you can text him
and let him know whether or not you
think he's a chair
that's from a previous episode by the
way i think it was our obligations
episode
anyway i wanted to just uh button this
up by
reading this one sentence again it's
striking to me that you don't seem to
have
figured out what you personally believe
about creation
and god um well here wait a minute they
have all the answers
they figured it out well that's the
thing i don't want to
figure it out right i want to understand
and the reason you brought up the
the sort of uh the term you used was
agnostic or
and really what you're saying is i don't
have an understanding but i'm attempting
to
to understand i'm i'm still i'm
searching i'm learning i'm seeking i
i'm i'm a seeker in ways and that's what
i think all these different traditions
do they sort of approximate a better
understanding
as opposed to figuring it
out i i don't you figure out something
that is i mean what is something that
you would figure out a puzzle
yeah i guess and i don't look at this as
a as a puzzle per se well there's
something about
you know the human existence this
you know mentality we have of having to
have answers
and you know what we've kind of been
discussing over the last couple months
has to do with not really having answers
in a way
so uh when i think about value judgments
it's like we work so hard
to get the answers so we can make the
appropriate value judgments on things
and the more and more let's talk about
some of those value judgments are for
people who are just catching up here so
one value judgment could be like you
should drink more water
or it should it could be you should stop
eating
uh you shouldn't eat that right you
should or shouldn't those are sort of
valuable sugar shouldn'ts good and bad
yeah right right yeah you must do this
you need to do this yeah it can be value
judgments as well
right and like the older i get the more
comfortable i get with
not having the answers and
it's almost like right now if i was to
you know put my flag
in here's the point of life you know i
think living a meaningful life is
important and it's great and it helps me
like
enjoy life but
the point of life for me right now is to
accept that there is
no rhyme or reason and that it just is
yes and uh that has
really helped me to especially get
through the times we're living in right
now which
it seems like you have to put a value
judgment on certain things
and certainly like there are things that
i would not associate with and
things i wouldn't promote um however
you know after it's all said and done
like it's it's
uh it's just everything is just
happening and
not having to put a value judgment on it
has helped me navigate it a little bit
better
now some people might mistake that for
nihilism what is nihilism
expound for the folks at home so so
nihilism is basically
the the i mean so if you want to read
more about it you can look at the
nietzsche's work and
you could even look at like some of the
existentialists uh heidegger
and and kierkegaard and it's so funny
because i studied those
guys in college and i really couldn't
tell you anything about them right
because if
you're not ready to hear a thing right
then it's just
going to fill up space it's gonna it's
gonna seem like hyper
rational and it's not gonna have a whole
lot to do with
uh with whatever's on your mind at the
time whatever interests you
then so nihilism is basically the belief
that there is nothing
uh and um there's no point to any of it
there's no meaning whatsoever
and uh you know i'm not an expert on on
any of these these topics but
i have you know i've read quite a bit on
uh
on different philosophies and what i'll
say
is that when you and i talk about living
a meaningful life
we don't think that there is inherent
meaning in
in everything or there is a thing you're
supposed to do
also a value judgment right or that you
were predestined or born
to be an astronaut or whatever it is
the the truth is that while there is not
a
a meaning we impart meaning onto
anything or we can at least and
unfortunately we often map meaning onto
virtually everything
it's the reason we have 300 000 items in
our households
is because we've said that well what
about the things that are
meaningful to me that's true you do have
some meaningful things but it's only
because you've assigned meaning
to them they're not innately meaningful
and so i can certainly see some wisdom
within nihilism
and i mean there's clearly some some
genius philosophers who
have who have written about it but i do
find
that we when it comes to living a
meaningful life
it's about finding what do we
add meaning to and if i do so
deliberately then i can live a
meaningful life that
is more peaceful more tranquil less
stressful
less anxious as as a result
we're talking about success today i
thought we'd start with a question here
from ladina in berlin although i don't
have any difficulties fulfilling
obligations that were imposed on me
i do struggle with tasks and steps
towards the goals that i set and want to
accomplish myself
for me it seems way harder to wake up
early over concentrated on something
that i don't have to do but i just want
to do i start procrastinating and
filling my time with passive activities
like senseless scrolling through youtube
or netflix or even worse
with buying stuff that i don't need
after which i do not feel happy or
content
so my question is this what advice would
you guys give me in order for me to stop
procrastinating and gaining the
necessary discipline for the meaningful
tasks
that i put upon myself and how would you
think minimalism would be helpful in
this regard
so ladina i you know i'm looking at at
your question here
hearing what you have to say and
you asked for some advice and i don't
know that i have any advice but i have
some observations
for you when you're talking about being
happy or being content the way that
you're talking about it it
it feels as though you're chasing the
thing you're chasing happiness and
the pursuit of happiness i think is
actually a problem i don't think
happiness can be pursued in fact i think
that
that the pursuit of happiness is a chase
and that is a type of
failure in a way right because it leads
to attachment it leads to
to misery and and so paradoxically the
chase to happiness
always leads to misery but
that said she's basically saying how do
i overcome my addiction to
procrastination so i can focus on
doing meaningful work well
it sounds to me like maybe you haven't
found what that meaningful
work is just yet now there are certain
things where you're like you know i
found this thing that i want to do
but maybe you don't have the deep desire
to do it there's a giant difference
between
wanting something and having the desire
for something you know for me wanting a
million dollars if
ryan you were to place a million dollars
in my bank account
yeah that sounds nice sure but i don't
have the deep desire to go out and
ruthlessly
make a million dollars this year right
and because there are certain levers i
could pull i could go back and work in
the corporate world and maybe i
i wouldn't make a million dollars in a
year but i'd be much much closer if i
went in and did that and climbed the
corporate ladder
but that's not a a price that i'm
willing to pay
really right and so when we think about
the deep desire i think it's about
uncovering
what that is because i wake up early it
doesn't mean you should
wake up early but when i wake up early
the first thing i do is write
why it's not because i i want to
right in a weird way it's because i have
to write now ryan there are two kinds of
haves here
there's the have where it's like ryan
i'm going to make you come into the
office at 9 00 a.m and you're going to
write every single morning
that's the external you're forced to do
something you have to do it yeah
and that's really what ladina means in
her question here is like
no one's forcing me to do this and so
i'm less inspired to do it yeah it's
interesting because she started off her
question with i'm really good at doing
the things i'm
forced my forced obligations i think is
what she said right
yeah and and so but i can't imagine if
someone forced me to write every morning
all of a sudden it would change the
total dynamic
however yeah i have to write every
morning but it's not an external have
it's a it's the thing i can't not do
and and if you have found the thing that
you can't
not do that is often what people mean
when they say
what am i supposed to do with my life
right
now of course there can be more than one
thing and the thing that i can't not do
right now at age 39
may be different when i'm 49 or 59
uh and and and i've lived my life
differently and so
that can change over time as well yeah
and so my observation is if we have
found
the thing that we can't not do whether
it's writing
or snowboarding or roasting
coffee or accounting whatever that thing
is that you
can't not do if you have found that
everything else just falls in line it
takes care of itself
you no longer if you ladina if you found
the thing you can't
not do you no longer need
discipline you no longer need commitment
you no longer need routine or schedule
or structure
because you develop a healthy obsession
for that thing a sort of borderline
pathology
in order to this is the thing that i
feel like i
must do there's nothing that i'd rather
be doing
than this it doesn't mean that it's easy
all the time
but it's the thing you can't not do and
so of course
you do it let's talk about
you know when the minimalist first came
about
um i'm curious well actually let me
preface it with this do you think it's
possible to
have an interest create the discipline
to invest in that interest and then
cultivate it into being something
that you can't not do that's a great
question right yeah
and and the answer is yes but
and or maybe yes and yeah yes and
it's important to realize that if you
have an interest in something
you may be able to cultivate it into a
passion or the thing you can't not
do but the
habits alone will certainly not do that
for you
i'll give you an example for me it was
writing right and so this is what i know
and for the longest time i was an
aspiring writer i talked about this in
my writing class how to write better
and i was an aspiring writer which meant
i didn't really write every day but it
was really the thing i
wanted i didn't have the deep desire yet
but i wanted
to do it and that's that's that's key
i wanted to do it and so i started
setting my alarm for 444
every morning this is before the jay-z
album of that same name
4 44. um and so i was in my 20s and
i i would basically i used to get up at
at 5 45 i started at 4 44. give me a
minute to get out of bed to get to my
desk
and start writing and at the moment did
i
need that sort of discipline yeah i
thought i did
but what that discipline created for me
early on is it
uncovered the deep desire
to write and now if it wouldn't have
created
it wouldn't have uncovered that deep
desire in fact it may have uncovered the
opposite whereas like oh this isn't
actually what i want to do
what's important there is that we don't
get stuck
in commitment because imagine if i
committed to continue writing even
though i hated it
well that's what a lot of people do well
i'm supposed to do this there is no
supposed right yeah totally
yeah it's it makes me yeah it makes me
think like well
uh i figured who you sat with is it don
delillo sit in the chair who is that oh
um
uh pollock donald ray pollock donald ray
[ __ ] yeah he wrote the devil all the
time which
was turned into a phenomenal movie
recently have you seen the movie no it's
out on netflix now
he's from chillicothe ohio yeah and yeah
great guy
so you sat with him and you're like you
know give me some advice and he's like
sit in the chair
yes and and may you know i think that's
it can be taken two ways right exactly
it can be taken as
you have the discipline to sit in the
chair uh-huh which and maybe that's how
it starts out and but then
ultimately it turns into like
you have to want to sit in the chair you
have to have a deep desire to sit in the
chair
yes that's exactly it man in fact i
think the the the ultimate lesson that i
i got from that only in retrospect
though because you're right at first it
almost felt like a prescription
yes just sit in the chair every day in
fact in my writing class that's how i
initially started it was like sit in the
chair for at least an hour a day for 30
days i'm gonna show you how to
write better yeah and and so yes from a
mechanical standpoint that works really
well and your writing will improve
drastically if for example you take
my writing class or any other writing
class and you spend 30 days sitting in
the chair
even if it doesn't become your deep
desire all of a sudden you're a writer
anyway
your mechanics will improve your text
messages your business emails
your whatever your journaling all that
will improve but when it comes to
going beyond the basic mechanics of the
thing
right you're right you have to have that
deep desire and i think ultimately what
donald ray pollock was saying to me
is hey you if you are a writer
writer's right right and the only way to
do that is not via osmosis
it's weird because i have a friend who
was a bricklayer
uh growing up um he grew up in the same
neighborhood as me went to the
vocational school
al you probably remember oh yeah yeah he
did bricklaying
and you never have aspiring bricklayers
you simply lay bricks or you don't
right you've you've spent your time
doing the thing and you become better at
it through
the the that routine of doing it but
someone who has a deep desire to build
something will automatically become a
bricklayer or or you know some other
creator of something yeah and ultimately
if we're talking about
to tie in the the question of meaning
and laura's question from earlier her
text message question
um if if we're really talking about
creation and creators let's say it
sounds to me like laura thinks that um
she um has has a courage
creator she has a faith that she has a
creator whoever that is
it can be you know god or jesus or
muhammad or allah or you can
it could be nature or source or whatever
you want to call it
if you feel like you have a creator
that you were created in the image of
well then you are also a creator and i
think it's a commonality
for each of us in fact ladina i want to
send you an advanced copy of our book
love people use things because there's
an entire chapter in there it's a
relationship book
but it's about the seven essential
relationships in our life one of those
is our relationship with creativity
and ryan you recall in that chapter we
talk about you can't really have a
relationship
you can't talk about your relationship
with creativity unless you talk about
your relationship to
distractions yeah and of course what is
our
number one weapon of mass distraction um
technology
yeah i mean that's it's ladina again
like josh and i are trying to get out of
the advice business um but i can
speak from my point of view if you
really want to cultivate
a passion for something like you got to
get rid of the distractions that
is number one and i was gonna and maybe
we don't have time to talk about this
but i was gonna talk about how
you got rid of your phone you got rid of
your internet and you
basically got rid of all your
distractions and you're very very
productive
let's let's extend that um real quick
i'll just let you know ladina i will
send you a copy of love people use
things it's actually coming out in
germany i think in early 2022. i'm not
sure
the minimalists.com actually just go to
lovepeopleusethings.net
if you want to pre-order the book also
ryan and i are doing the audiobook on
this one
and i think we're gonna do something
special with the audiobook
i want to disagree with parts of the
book in real time as we continue to
evolve
so i'm going to try and get the
publisher to allow us to sort of do a
little mini
podcast at the end of each chapter of
the audiobook that's available for
pre-sale right now
and also uh if you're on our newsletter
this is going to be published in dozens
of countries i know a lot of you
the only reason i mention is a lot of
you dozens of you have reached out to us
on social media and text and
and on the uh email and asked when or
when is it going to be published in
portugal or wherever
and the answer is stay tuned for details
it'll be in dozens
of languages lovepeopleusthings.net is
the website ryan let's talk about some
of those distractions
so man yes and
at the time i thought what was important
was getting rid of those distractions
so that i could write but what
here's here's the truth what's the the
direct truth behind the matter
the deep desire to write removed the
distractions
meant because i had such a deep desire
to write
i needed to get rid of the things
that were keeping me from doing the
thing i can't not do
and that it wasn't just the technology
there it was like i'm going to move into
a smaller apartment
my rent was 900 a month how can i make
it
a month how can i afford to do this if
i'm not making any money and by the way
it's my it's my favorite thing that i
still do with the minimalist if you're
on our newsletter you know i send out a
weekly sort of
musing about minimalism or success or
whatever and
about failure about attachment about
relationships
and it's just what's on my mind and
there's no monetary sort of thing
attached to that in fact it costs a lot
of money for
to write what i write because we have a
newsletter list with hundreds of
hundreds of thousands of people yeah and
it's very expensive to maintain a list
like that when i'm not
yet we don't charge if i charge everyone
a dollar
for the writings wow but because it's
it's free it's not it's not tainted at
all i never feel like
i'm obligated to provide something
i just simply write because i can't not
do it and i would still do it even if we
didn't publish it on the blog
even if we didn't publish it via the
minimalist
newsletter because it's the thing i
can't not do i wake up
early in the morning up at 4 30 this
morning and
i just started writing and
some writing days i'll write a thousand
two thousand words other days i'll write
negative three thousand words
because it's all part of the process
right so yes
removing those distractions was actually
a result of finding the thing that i
can't not do so the question ladina is
how bad do you want to do those things
enough to remove those distractions
and here's the thing too though you know
ladina i don't know
uh i like to play guitar i like to play
saxophone i take spanish lessons
um those aren't things that are deep
desires that i can't not do
but i enjoy them right and there are
things that uh
i will practice um i don't have a set
schedule for it
i'm not going to be a professional
anything when it comes to those three
things
and that's okay and i've accepted that
well let's look at one of those things
sure imagine if it was guitar sure and i
said all right ryan now every morning
at 4 30 a.m you have to get up and
practice guitar
for an hour yeah now first off without a
doubt you would become
better mechanically yes within the first
30 days for sure
no question about that
but is that the cost you're willing to
pay
and the answer to that right now is
obviously no right
it but if it became the thing all of a
sudden you realize like wow
this is the thing i can't not do then
great
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a big deal
at all for you to get up early and start
playing for an hour i wonder if john
mayer would have become john mayer
if he you know started playing guitar in
like the year 2010 with all the
distractions
right he's actually i've heard him say
that one of the greatest benefits of his
childhood
was not growing up with the internet
yeah because it allowed him to sit in
his room for eight hours a night and
practice guitar
right he had no choice right yeah and
here's the thing i think that
someone with someone like john mayer i
think the answer to that is still yes
because i think so it is the thing i
mean he's proficient at quite a few
things
and a really bright person but but he is
a savant
guitar player perhaps the best in the
world or one of the best in the world
people don't realize that because he's a
pop singer but
uh guitar enthusiasts know that he is
he's the real deal yeah
right and it's because of that obsession
that pathological obsession for
greatness so
ultimately yes the answer is if you want
to become better at something
mechanically
then yeah some discipline and some
practice
those things are all fine if you want to
be elite or
great or find that thing that you're
really
able to impart meaning on it's gonna go
beyond that that sort of discipline i
think where ladina
is really uh i don't know at a
crossroads right now
is these are shoulds so she's like you
know she's shooting all over herself
which is which is fine
but ladini you've got to be honest with
yourself like
how badly do you want to do those things
because
one or two things will happen either
ladina you will get rid of the
distractions
and you'll develop this deep desire you
will turn those things into
into you know things that you can't not
do or
you can just accept that you know what
those aren't things that you really want
to do and that's okay too
yes but right now she's in this
crossroads with the shoulds
right and i love what you're saying
there about because quite often you feel
like you should do something by the way
here's a gift
for you ladina there is no should and so
we need to set that aside all together
the problem that we've encountered is
our culture has
has brought in a whole lot of shoulds
the opposite ryan of
of nihilism is rational totalitarianism
where people and groups overly moralize
everything where it's everything is
binary you should do this you shouldn't
do that well binary thinking produces
grayscale rainbows that's a minimal
maximum from a previous episode but you
can
tweet that podcast sean and here's what
i'll say
there is no should those are
myths manufactured by your culture or by
your society
and when you realize that you get to
create your own
musts as a result i must do this this is
the thing i can't not do not because
my culture said i should do it but
because i feel
so compelled to have that deep desire
to do it all right for the sake of time
ryan
let's take patrick's question about
finding uh
work life balance and uh
we're gonna take that on the private
podcast
this week because well ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it's time
for the lightning round where we answer
your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654
now during the lightning round so ryan
and i do our best to answer questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you'd like
and now you can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place
minimalmaxims.com sia has a question for
us
what's your advice for situations when
you had a
clear vision to achieve success slash
happiness but it falls apart due
to external forces how do you rebuild
yourself
and restructure the idea of success in
your head
interesting that someone's happiness and
success
they made it one word literally yeah is
and it falls apart due to external
forces
always yeah right so let me give you my
pithy answer maybe we can unpack this
together ryan
happiness is not a byproduct of success
it is a byproduct of enough
we don't ever stop to consider what is
enough yeah in our culture it's always
more
more more and and we rarely stop to
consider less
because that almost seems that's
counter-cultural you and i never set out
to be
counter-cultural as the minimalists but
in a way it is a rejection of a
consumerism culture because we realized
exactly what cia was saying here success
slash happiness which by the way she
puts it as one word because it's
success slash happiness well that's the
problem we've
attached happiness to success
now that's a foolish thing for us to do
the reason that we uh
call our audience simpletons by the way
because ryan and i are the head
simpletons
simpleton just means that we're we're
foolish right and what is the
most foolish thing that i have done in
my life well perhaps the most foolish is
i equated success with happiness as soon
as i get that thing
that external thing that person or thing
then i will be happy
and then when i'm happy i'll be actually
the other way around then i'll be
successful and as soon as i'm successful
then
i will be happy of course it falls apart
due to external forces
that's how it always falls apart here's
one more pit the answer for you ryan
he who settles for success is a
successful
hence the title of this episode so
all i'm really trying to say here ryan
is that when we
pursue success when we pursue
happiness it is a type of failure we're
going to address this on the private
podcast i got a whole essay called
success does not exist and i have an
equation in there i know how you love
math equations i love it
and so i will prove to you
mathematically how success
equals failure ryan you got some of the
pithy for us
i do uh love is the foundation upon
which
success is built let me tell you why i
love this ryan
because what you're doing here is you're
redefining the culture's idea of success
yeah i mean when i think about
me being a successful person it has
nothing to do with
titles or followers or you know
money it has everything to do with can i
be myself 100 can i be who ryan
nicodemus is and do i have people in my
life
who i can support and also be supported
by
and that is uh that's a good life and
you could put a million dollars in my
bank account or take all my money away
um having those things for me helps me
feel uh i guess yeah successful
yeah so there's nothing wrong with
success the problem is
hey the definition the meaning that we
give success and b
like what are we putting aside to
chase that success so going back to the
corporate world we associated success
with happiness
yes but how many of our values did we
step on
how many things did we ignore in order
to be successful
chasing the happiness and arguably we
got there
but yeah you know happiness is ephemeral
we we paid that cost
right and then realized like oh this
isn't worth
the cost that we're paying because of
all the additional costs yeah
it first looked like okay work 60 hours
a week but then all the other calls were
stress and anxiety and overwhelm and
and you end up in a place where you
don't want to be
well how do you end up there because you
chase success around success ryan
it's like when you take a balloon and
blow it up and you just let it go
and all of a sudden we're just chasing
it all over the room right you ever do
that with
i've done it with ella a bunch of times
i'll just blow up a balloon and let it
and she'll try to chase it she'll never
ever catch it
but what a perfect metaphor for
happiness is you already had the
happiness right there
and you let it go and you start chasing
it you never
ever catch it it's like uh
well it's making me think there's
there's something there with a metaphor
about ella having a lot of fun
with the chase which then makes me think
about a dog that chases its tail they
get so excited but when they
as soon as they catch their tail they're
like now what they're confused
right right yeah and by the way that's
what happened to me and you
we caught our tail in our 20s yeah
and it was like oh wait a minute
now now what do i do i've caught the you
know
what i i need a bigger tail to catch now
right
yeah uh and and so it always
sort of success or happiness is always
sort of right around the bin
we never ever get there there's there
there is something about
never getting there though the there's
something about the chase that is
fun yeah but it's so so the question is
is that and and i don't know the answer
to this is
we're always chasing something like i am
chasing
uh peace right now so i i think we're
always
chasing something you are chasing good
health right now you're you're you're
uh we're so i guess the question is is
like do we
do we accept that we shouldn't chase
or do we be more deliberate with the
things we chase i have a very long
answer for that we'll do it on the
private party
this week because i do want to disagree
with you on the chasing part but i think
maybe we could form a dayton
in the middle there was no there was i
didn't put my flag anywhere to disagree
with we said we're all chasing something
and and oh i
want to help you okay i want to have a
conversation about that okay cool gotcha
also we've got some listener comments
and tips this week and an added value
segment that you're certainly going to
enjoy but first looks like we've got a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
would you please talk about your private
podcast disagreement from last month
what do you mean when you say that
success is the same thing as
failure how has your definition of
success changed since becoming
the minimalists what can you do to get
rid of perfectionism
how do you find work-life balance what
is the difference between satisfaction
and fulfillment plus a million
phenomenal questions about success
for the minimalist and i i don't say
that lightly ryan you rarely ever hear
me say that's a great question so when i
do say it i
genuinely mean it i don't know what sort
of magic podcast sean put together
to tweeze out some of these questions uh
for this week but man
sean you picked some phenomenal
questions they're gonna make for some
good conversations here and if you wanna
listen to all that
listen to the minimalist private podcast
this week visit the
minimalists.com support to subscribe and
get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app it's cheaper than a cup of coffee
and it keeps our show 100 percent
advertisement free by the way private
podcast subscribers also gain access to
hundreds of hours of our private
archives
ryan what else you got for us this week
josh that's a great question here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hello
my name is maggie and i'm from northport
michigan
i wanted to leave a comment addressing
gifts i recently saw a local news story
about a little girl who loved dogs
so she asked for birthday gifts such as
dog food
and toys that would then be donated to
their local animal shelter
so then i thought for mother's day
you could ask for items that then could
be donated to the local women's shelter
also around christmas there's usually
toy drives
and winter coat and boot drives and a
last idea
for children is their classroom at
school
being adopted to supply with
some basic items that their class could
need
hi this is emily from romer park
california i was really moved by your
collection collecting episode and i
wanted to talk about
how studying art history in college i
was very seduced by this history of
beautiful objects and started collecting
into myself
at a young age and found it actually
really quieting for my mind
to focus all my attention on this one
object
and studying it and appreciating its
beauty and it was only over time that i
came to realize it wasn't owning these
things that brought pleasure but
actually just
feeling reverent for them and i was able
to sell
my collections without losing much money
because the interests hold their value
which sadly is not the case with most
objects in the world
and now i can move through this world of
objects
and appreciate them and then just leave
them in the world the same way we
take a hike in the woods and we don't
feel like we need to bring home the
trees and rocks and creatures we just
enjoy being immersed in that environment
and
enjoy it while we're there and i think
too often people think
that when you're a minimalist you have a
kind of disdain for things
and that you shun them and reject them
and that's just not the case you can
still very much enjoy
objects and be amused by the
novel chicas at the store or the
beautiful jewelry on people's wrists and
you just don't have to own it so
reverence is different than ownership
you know the great question thing is is
fascinating right it's an idiom that i
always use i don't know why
i can tell you why it's like a buffer
it's like that's exactly it's like
saying um
yeah yeah and by the way i have old
videos you go back and look at the
minimalists there are plenty of videos
of me saying oh good question great
and the thing is what we're also trying
to do is we're trying to make the other
person feel comfortable
and accepted we accept your question
right but in a weird way
it was me accidentally patronizing the
person because
they would say something like hey
where's the bathroom oh good question
it's
it's not a good question yeah so um
anyway we have an added value segment
this week ryan
and i was telling you about this i sent
you his new album wesley schultz
has a album called vignettes why is
there a letter g
in the word vignettes i don't know man
the english language is weird although i
would
i would say that's probably not english
yeah it's probably it's a romance
it's a derivative of a romance language
yeah anyway uh
wesley schultz like who is this anyway i
turned it on i'm like this guy
he's doing like his best lumineers
impersonation it sounds
i mean this is almost exactly like the
lumineer
and then i realized like what wait these
are 10 cover songs
it sounds like a guy's doing a
lumineer's impression
of a coldplay song or a bruce
springsteen song or a bob dylan song or
a sheryl crowe song
that's weird and then i realized oh wait
wesley schultz is the lead singer
from the lumineers so it's gonna have
that lumineers-esque sound
which ryan does a good impression of
you can't do that we're getting pulled
off youtube oh my copyright infringement
my bad
yeah so um he has a new album wesley
schultz it's called
vignettes and at the end of this episode
podcast shawn the
the opening song is a bruce springsteen
song it is called my city of ruins
and i i will tell you that what a great
song
but what an especially great song at the
tail end of this what i hope is the tail
end of a pandemic
right to be talking about a city of
ruins when you look at
a city like new york city i think it was
a hundred and sixteen thousand people
left new york city last year
oh wow i mean that is staggering right i
don't know if that stat is 100 accurate
i just i saw it the other day and um
what is fascinating to me is we're
starting to look
even through old art they're
illuminating something
about the current world and so
at the end of this we'll listen to
wesley schultz's my city of ruins and
real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalist i have
a free ebook
it's called 11 ways to write better
we've talked a bit about writing
on this episode you can find it over at
howtowritebetter.org
also i teach a writing class it's not
open currently so you can't enroll in it
but
if you're on the email list over there
we'll let you know if and when it opens
up
in the near future but in the meantime
you can download that free ebook it's
called
11 ways to write better you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalist come to one
of our live podcast shows visit
theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email voice
memo to podcast at theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
slash the minimalist and if you want our
show notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple sunday emails each week
and if you leave here today with just
one message
we hope it's this love people
and use things otherwise you're a
failure
see you all right y'all thanks a lot
thanks for listening
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it